Aston Martin's been making cars for more
than a century now and like anyone who's
wrinkles have wrinkles it's not always
great with change
it's gone more than 10 years without a
serious upgrade to the body structure
that underpins its cars its infotainment
system sucks even the looks are getting
stale until now the 2017 DB 11 is Aston
Martin's much-needed revamp the 212
thousand-dollar car is a fresh take on
the company's famed design language
inside the car is stuffed with leather
made from Scotland's fanciest cows the
infotainment system wild from Mercedes
actually works well the digital
instrument cluster does away with Aston
famed anti clockwise rotating tachometer
but such as the price of progress but
the DB 11s most significant bid for the
future is under the hood peasants you
may keep your downsized foreign
six-cylinder engines Aston is loyal to
the v12 this twin turbocharged unit
delivers 600 horsepower enough to send
the grand touring car from zero to 60
miles per hour in under four seconds
essence latest is thoroughly digital the
onboard computers calculate the car
speed acceleration and position to
continually adjust the suspension for
optimal performance
yes change is hard but the DB 11 shows
essence got more than a few more
birthdays to look forward to